le carceri andrebbero chiuse abolite
subito perché Perché non funzionano o
meglio Ogni tanto funzionano con chi non
ne ha bisogno
quando sono stato invitato a parlare qui
a Noventa Vicentina mi è stato detto che
il tema era fare Lucio ho pensato
perfetto Non dovrò neanche
alzare più di tanto quello che è il mio
intervento perché non esistono luoghi
più bui dei carceri
lavoro in carcere da 12 anni e ho
cominciato per tanti motivi credo che un
po' abbia anche influito la visione di
un film I meno giovani se lo
ricorderanno si chiamava Mary per sempre
c'era un Michele Placido straordinario
evidentemente quel film Un po' mi ha
toccato Insomma sono cresciuto Si
autopsicologia ho cominciato a lavorare
nelle carceri faccio un lavoro che non
ha una definizione ben precisa Infatti
tuttora i miei genitori non sanno che
lavoro faccio Mio padre dice basta che
ti pagano poi va bene comunque
sarebbe l'operatore della grave
marginalità
ho studiato psicologia ma non faccio lo
psicologo non sono un assistente sociale
mi occupo di progetti di reinserimento
sociale cioè traghetto i detenuti da
fuori da dentro Scusate a fuori il
carcere faccio colloquio Mi interfaccio
con I magistrati con gli assistenti
sociali e provo a trovare loro un lavoro
una casa cercare di mettere in ordine un
po' la loro vita
all'inizio è stato difficilissimo perché
io venivo da tutt'altra esperienza e il
carcere è un microcosmo con
caratteristiche molto particolari
intanto ha un linguaggio tutto suo
dopo una settimana di lavoro un ragazzo
che mi era stato
affidato ha chiesto colloquio e tutto
affannato e preoccupato mi ha detto
Paolo ho un problema perché ho fatto
casino all'aria e probabilmente Un
agente mi ha fatto rapporto e ho perso i
giorni tutto perché qualcuno mi ha
montato una bicicletta per mandarmi tra
gli infami
io l'ho ascoltato vedevo lui molto
preoccupato ma sinceramente non avevo
capito niente del concetto che aveva
espresso allora poi nel tempo invece ho
imparato che ad esempio l'aria e quel
momento che detenuti passano fuori dalla
cella più volte al giorno per poter
socializzare con gli altri ho capito che
rapporto era quella relazione che la
gente mitenziario mi raccomando agente
Penitenziario e non Secondino o guardia
faceva al detenuto che si era comportato
male un po' il corrispettivo della nota
scolastica
Ho imparato che montare una bicicletta
dentro il carcere voleva dire inventarsi
una storia per creare un danno a
qualcuno nello specifico
stava girando la voce che quel ragazzo
avesse fatto dei nomi quindi avesse
fatto arrestare altre persone quindi
definito un infame e gli infami
all'interno del carcere così come si
chiamano tra di loro Il termine
assolutamente triste e inopportuno
vengono ottenuti separati da tutti gli
altri e tenuti comuni in sezioni
protette per tutelarli sono sezioni
attenzionate in quella sezione vengono
tenute anche i sexofenders vengono
tenuti Chi ha commesso violenza su
minori Chi ha iniziato a collaborare con
la giustizia e anche chi si è dichiarato
omosessuale ad esempio Quindi tutte
persone che vivono in una condizione
particolare che potrebbero sentirsi in
pericolo in mezzo agli altri detenuti
comuni e poi allora nel tempo ho
sviluppato iniziato a vivere il carcere
in modo più intenso Ci sono
delle caratteristiche tipo il frastuono
dei blindi che si aprono e si chiudono
ogni 10 secondi i blindi sono le porte
di ferro che separano le celle dai
corridoi ma anche le sezioni dalle altre
sezioni ed è un rumore un rumore
assordante che ti entra dentro che poi
spesso ti porti anche a casa ci sono
odori particolari che io ho sentito
soltanto in carcere tipo
l'alito di un detenuto in terapia
metabolica alle otto e mezza del mattino
dopo già la terza sigaretta
ti trovi a fare dei colloqui in
condizioni davvero difficile oltre a
essere difficile di per sé il lavoro
allora ho iniziato a capire che c'erano
degli aspetti che nessuno conoscevo che
conosceva in pochi e che forse valeva la
pena raccontare anche attraverso i
social e quindi sono partito proprio con
il glossario del carcere quindi
raccontavo che cosa voleva dire cos'era
la domandina che la lettera che la gente
che che il detenuto chiedeva agli
operatori per avere una qualche forma di
disservizio ho raccontato cos'era la
sezione protetta e prima su sui social
su Facebook poi su Instagram poi sono
arrivato su Tik Tok nel 2019 circa
esploso un interesse particolare per
questo tema siamo arrivati in un mese
circa 50.000 follower e io vedevo queste
visualizzazioni vedevo questi like e mi
chiedevo come fosse possibile che i miei
video che si inserivano in mezzo alla
ballerina che turcava il costume da
bagno e il ragazzo che si allenava in
palestra tutto sudato questo video
potesse suscitare l'interesse di
qualcuno Eppure è stato così allora ho
detto bene una grandissima occasione
parliamone approfittiamo di questa
piattaforma che in modo inaspettato sta
dimostrando tutto questo interesse
cominciamo a parlarne allora ho
cominciato a fare video e i follower le
persone su Tik Tok spesso molto giovani
hanno cominciato a farmi domande e ci
sono delle domande che hanno avuto
diciamo più successo di altre quindi
Piffer Ma è vera la leggenda della
saponetta
ad esempio no questa è una delle poche
leggende non vere tristi che il carcere
ha tantissimi difetti ma non è vero che
un detenuto non si può chinare a
raccogliere la saponetta nelle docce
salvo poi essere eventualmente diciamo
violentato No questa cosa nelle nostre
carceri non succede Diciamo che un poco
al cinema a un po' diciamo giocato ha
influenzato a suggestionato un po' gli
spettatori mi chiedono
dell'autoerotismo Ma i detenuti che
magari devono scontare 2 anni 5 anni 10
anni possono fare autoerotismo in
carcere
Certo che sì nel senso non si potrebbe
Ma si sono organizzati
ad esempio come fanno a raggiungere una
loro intimità per evitare di mancare di
rispetto naturalmente ai cancellini Si
coordinano e quindi si mettono d'accordo
e decidono che quel giorno lì tutti i
concettini vanno all'aria tranne uno che
può rimanere nella cella e quindi poter
soddisfare le proprie pulsioni sessuali
questo tema che può fare un po'
sorridere in realtà quello del diritto
alla sessualità è un tema molto molto
importante che altri paesi europei hanno
deciso di affrontare con più coraggio
noi abbiamo sempre dopo su questi temi
dove centro un po' la morale arriviamo
dopo ma in alcuni paesi hanno ritenuto
riconoscere il diritto alla sessualità
perché fondamentale nel progetto di
rieducazione
un'altra domanda classica è Ma allora
possono essere rieducati tutti mi
possono articoli di persone che hanno
commesso crimini violenti mi dicono Ah
quindi anche lui quindi tutti possono
essere educati
la risposta è no non tutti perché ci
sono detenuti che non vogliono essere
Aiutati Allora non si può aiutare chi
non vuole essere aiutato ma con tutti
gli altri noi abbiamo il dovere
di offrire una seconda possibilità e poi
magari fallire ma abbiamo questo dovere
ci sono tante altre domande Adesso va
molto di moda quella sul 41 bis
Soprattutto dopo l'arresto del boss
mafioso Matteo Messina
io rispondo sì Ma voi sapete che cos'è
il 41 bis che regime è che cosa comporta
Perché molti pensano che il 41 bis sia
semplicemente una condizione dove il
detenuto deve stare un po' Peggio degli
altri perché ha commesso un crimine più
grave non c'entra nulla il 41 bis è una
condizione di isolamento particolare
dove la persona può avere meno colloqui
non può ricevere riviste giornali
dall'esterno anche quando incontri
familiari durante i colloqui spesso sono
divisi da un vetro per evitare gli
scambi l'obiettivo del 41 bis è quello
di impedire che la persona possa
comunicare con l'esterno non quello di
creare dolore alla persona o sofferenza
questo è molto importante fatta questa
premessa
quando mi chiedono se sono favorevole al
contrario il 41 bis io rispondo ancora
oggi non lo so perché il tema è molto
delicato ci hanno messo teste e cuore
persone come Falcone e Borsellino io mi
sento sinceramente in imbarazzo oggi a
dire è tutto sbagliato bisogna fare così
bisogna fare allora è chiaro che ci sono
delle incompatibilità soprattutto con
l'articolo 3 della convenzione Europea
dei diritti umani quello che dice che
non si può torturare le persone
però non voglio neanche diciamo cerco di
resistere a questa tentazione e non mi
vergogno di dire che per il momento non
lo so sto studiando e sto maturando la
mia posizione un'altra domanda molto
diffusa che mi viene fatta ogni giorno
dove invece sono sicuro da risposta è la
pena di morte se favorevole al contrario
la pena di morte Ecco Su questo non ho
dubbi senza andare a disturbare il buon
Beccaria dei diritti e delle pene Io
credo che la pena di morte in uno stato
di diritto non possa esistere lo stato
non può mettersi sullo stesso piano del
criminale e anche chi in qualche modo
tifa per la pena di morte e utilizza lo
strumento della
lo definisce come dei torrente un
deterrente efficace no ormai tutte le
ricerche ci hanno dimostrato che dove
c'è la pena di morte
non ci sono meno reati quindi non
funziona neanche come deterrente non c'è
un motivo un buon motivo per
reintrodurre la pena di morte
all'interno del nostro paese
un po' di numeri che non sono tutto ma
ci servono Per inquadrare il contesto in
Italia ci sono circa 54 mila detenuti
54.000 il 3% sono donne
il 30% sono stranieri che questa cosa
vuol dire concretamente che ci sono
delle difficoltà immese di comunicare
con la persona se già è difficile
provare a rieducare e reinserire una
persona che parla la tua lingua
figuriamoci chi non parla la nostra
lingua
tutto l'aspetto della mediazione
culturale Il 40% sono tossicodipendenti
tutto l'aspetto legata all'assistenza
sanitaria
quasi tutte le carceri sono
sovraffollate ci sono punte del centro
130%.
e c'è una recidiva nel nostro paese del
60 per cento vuol dire che più di un
detenuto quasi due ritenuti su tre
riconnettono reati dopo essere stati in
carcere
questa cosa Cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
il carcere non funziona
quel dato scende al 19% quando quel
detenuto è stato inserito in progetti di
inclusione sociale
questa cosa Cosa ci suggerisce ci
suggerisce che bisogna investire sul
reinserimento un detenuto costo al
giorno
1504 euro Come tenere un parente un
amico in un albergo al 4 stelle ogni
giorno
150 4 euro al giorno 35 centesimi
vengono spesi per il suo per la sua
rieducazione
un detenuto reinserito un detenuto che
ricomincia a lavorare che prende una
casa in affitto e un detenuto e una
persona che si trasforma da costo a
risorsa e non c'entra niente essere
buoni o essere cattivi Sì IP per tu dici
così perché Basta con questo buonismo
non c'entra niente il buonismo non
c'entra niente perché un carcere
efficiente un carcere efficace un
carcere che rieduca conviene a tutti
perché ci costa di meno e rendere nostre
città molto più sicure
diceva che se una pena non è
assolutamente necessaria
E tirannica ora cosa possiamo fare
Cosa possiamo fare per rendere tutta
questa situazione meno tragica e vi
ricordo che nel 2022 ci sono stati 84
suicidi nelle nostre carceri
un record purtroppo che apre anche tutto
tutta la questione della Salute Mentale
dentro il carcere che oggi le carceri
non riescono ad affrontare non hanno
risorse non hanno operatori Cosa
possiamo fare Allora intanto dobbiamo
convincerci tutti
che il carcere riguarda tutti
non soltanto i detenuti parenti dei
detenuti gli agenti penitenziari o la
famiglia della gente Penitenziario
riguarda tutti servono a politica
coraggiosa capace di fare riforme vere
qualche giorno fa è uscito un articolo è
andato a ribalta Nazionale un signore
dopo 17 anni è stato arrestato perché 17
anni fa aveva rubato 5 euro e 20
centesimi in un supermercato 5 euro di
cibo
capite che non è possibile che questo
accada
Allora bisogna investire
risorse nel reinserimento lavorativo
nel reinserimento abitativo
bisogna costruire strutture Sì certo Ma
soprattutto bisogna depenalizzare reati
altrimenti ci sarà sempre
sovraffollamento
dobbiamo continuare a parlarne e ognuno
deve fare la sua parte io sono qui Un
po' anche per questo anche oggi per
continuare a fare luce e se sono
riuscito un pochino a incuriosirvi ed
appassionarvi vi chiedo di aiutarmi a
continuare a fare luce
e non perché siete buoni ma perché avete
capito
quindi non buttiamo via la chiave Grazie
[Applauso]